If you thought Justice League was a mess,
it's important to remember things could've
been far, far worse.
Back in 1997, Joel Schumacher's Batman & Robin
nearly ruined comic book movies forever.
"Alright everyone, chill."
But surprisingly enough, it wasn't the worst
comic adaptation of that year.
CBS took a shot on piloting a TV series called
Justice League of America … but the results
made Batman & Robin look like The Dark Knight.
"Why so serious."
The premise was simple.
In fact, a little too simple.
It centered on Matthew Settle as Green Lantern,
alongside Kenny Johnston's The Flash, John
Kassiras The Atom, and Michelle Hurd as Fire.
These are all characters that have been associated
with Justice League in the comics, but the
kicker in this adaptation was that they were
all roommates and regular people with ordinary
problems.
It's as if CBS asked for DC's Super Friends
meets NBC's Friends.
"WHAT IS THE MATTER WITH YOU?"
In fact, it'd be shocking if that exact phrase
didn't come up during a pitch meeting.
Justice League of America turned out to be
a weird amalgam of an action-drama and a sitcom,
except the special effects were embarrassing
even by '90s standards and the comedy was
downright painful.
There were also extremely awkward interview
segments with the characters scattered throughout,
giving the whole thing a quasi-mockumentary
feel that interrupted any semblance of flow
it might've had.
But a lot of the problems came from the would-be
series botching the iconic characters at their
cores.
Green Lantern was shown as a software salesman
and was based on Guy Gardner from the comics
while looking more like the Kyle Rayner version
and being as dull as Hal Jordan from the Super
Friends cartoon.
"If it's a joust you want, it's a joust you'll
get!"
Meanwhile, The Flash was depicted as struggling
with unemployment despite his super-speed,
The Atom was a science teacher who could shrink
himself small enough to fix an old-school
TV, and Fire was a struggling actress who
definitely dressed up as a banana for a commercial
audition.
Then there was Martian Manhunter, played by
David Ogden Stiers from M*A*S*H, whose face
was always covered with a budget version of
what Jim Carrey wore The Mask.
Although that might all sound a little like
some hokey remake of The Incredibles, it wasn't.
"Man, it wasn't good enough."
Each character was unlikable in his or her
own way, and the plot was even worse.
In the episode, the team recruits a new member
in Ice, who started out as a meteorologist
in the town of….
New Metro.
Yes, that was the actual, completely uninspired
name of a city from the show.
After a freak lab accident gave Ice the ability
to freeze things, she worked with the other
heroes to take down the villainous Weatherman,
played by the late, great Miguel Ferrer.
Since the show didn't get past the pilot,
it's not clear if the plan was to feature
a new villain in each episode, but Ferrer
does a serviceable job in one of his trademark
bad guy roles.
But even that wasn't enough to redeem it.
The biggest problem with Justice League of
America was that it couldn't figure out if
it was a sitcom or something more serious.
While modern shows like Arrow, Supergirl,
and Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
find subtle ways to use humor as a balance
for the darker moments, this show went way
too far into family-friendly cheese to ever
make anything seem consequential.
Justice League of America never hit the air
in the U.S., although some overseas markets
may have seen it.
However, the pilot still has life thanks to
the wonders of the internet and bootleg screenings
shown at comic book conventions.
But it's not a cult following that's developed
in the wake of its modern availability; it
mostly just serves as a cautionary tale about
half-heartedly adapting beloved comic book
characters when you have little to no budget
or creative vision.
"I've just pushed people and run away"
We were all into different stuff two decades
ago, but it's difficult to believe anyone
would've ever been into this.
Although Zack Snyder's Justice League didn't
do as well as expected at the box office and
critics were certainly not kind, it looks
like a legitimate masterpiece compared to
this show.
"It has to."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!